eu vou contar pra vocês uma história
rapidamente à qual somos protagonistas e
alguns dos meus professores e alunos
também são a minha relação com a escola
sempre foi muito conflituoso
eu não suportava escola e eu acho que
ela também não suportava até chegar na
sexta série
as cestas eram um problema porque a
gente chega na sexta série
no início da nossa adolescência a gente
está ali um monte de dúvidas e
pensamentos e os nossos hormônios estão
em ebulição e eu já olhava pra minha
professores não achava mais ela somente
bonita eu começava a passar outras
partes do seu corpo mais interessante e
eu ficava ali dentro completamente
distraído e não deu outra
eu reprovei na sexta série mas como sou
perfeccionista e teimoso eu reprovei
pela segunda vez
na verdade eu me formei esta série
eu levei três anos para conseguir chegar
à sétima série
mas eu só consegui chegar à sétima série
porque eu mudei de escola e aí um tal de
conselho de classe e aprovou
aí eu terminei o primeiro grounds
rapidamente o segundo grau foi bem mais
fácil do que aquela sexta série e hoje a
gente chama de ensino médio aquilo que é
o segundo grau antes
e realmente não existe um nome melhor
pra isso que a gente chama de ensino
médio porque ele é médio é mediano para
baixo
ele não ensina nada de novo ele só
preparar os seus alunos para o
vestibular e agora mais recentemente
para o enem
eu terminei o segundo grau e aí eu
comecei uma faculdade eu parei dois
meses
aí outra estudar um pouco mais de 16
aí eu abandonei quem sabia me abandonado
há muito tempo e fui fazer uma coisa que
eu gostava e gosto até hoje futebol
montem uma escola de futebol
aí eu comecei a sentir que eu começava a
ser um professor
mesmo sem querer ser professor e isso
ficou muito evidente quando uma mãe
telefonou
a nossa escola de futebol aflita
procurando lugar para colocar o seu
filho
ele havia sido diagnosticado com
hiperatividade em 1994 já existia e
interatividade
aí eu estou lá e essa mãe falou meu
filho tem problemas de relacionamento
estável ea psicóloga recomendou que
fizesse uma atividade física e eu também
preciso de um descanso do sul chegou
sábado de manhã eu não aguento mais essa
criança
o escolhido foi a nossa escola de
futebol e eu estou lá no sábado de manhã
eu me lembro como se fosse hoje
aquele ônibus chegando cheio de crianças
e adolescentes
de repente o ônibus para o motorista mal
havia pisado no freio aposta sequer
havia sido aberta lá atrás da última
janela salto garotinho vai rolando pelo
chão se levanta vira grama ea terra do
joelho
chega perto de mim fala você o professor
da upe asa
eu falei você o sef o problema é que
você sabe eu já tem informações a seu
respeito
zezinho é o nome fictício esses acontece
que o regime trouxe outros problemas
porque o zezinho não veio sozinho
parece que reuniu todos os desenhos
brinquedos que tinha na cidade e trouxe
para treinar com ele
eu na verdade eu mais apertava brigas do
que ministrava treinamentos
aí eu precisava adotar uma estratégia
questão de sobrevivência da escola de
futebol
o que eu fiz na hora do coletivo que
eles vão jogar futebol e eles vão lá pra
isso pra jogar futebol eu ia montar as
equipes eu comecei a chamar os vizinhos
briguentos para serem os capitães das
equipes então 10 obrigando era o capitão
do time azul
o outro zezinho capitão do time amarelo
outro zezinho obrigando o capitão do
time branco e eu pegava o zezinho mais
briguentos de todos e dava a ele
o apito gente vocês não imaginam o poder
que o apito representa para algumas
pessoas
experimente fazer isso então com
crianças façam isso em casa
aí eu estava lidando com essas situações
mas o
não considerava que aquilo fosse
suficiente eu senti a necessidade de
melhorar as minhas táticas ampliar o meu
conhecimento
e aí eu não tenho uma necessidade com o
sonho de infância e fui fazer uma
faculdade de educação física
com 33 anos de idade eu entrei para o
curso superior
eu trabalhava todos os dias da semana o
dia inteiro ea noite eu ia pra assistir
às aulas na faculdade
nos quatro anos que eu mais me divertir
na minha vida eu ia observar os
professores e eu fui surpreendido por
alguns professores
eu tinha uma professora que ela reunia
turma em círculo na sala de aula
aí nós temos que olhar um para o outro
durante a aula
tudo que nós falávamos que nós
apresentávamos era olhando para os
nossos colegas
aí fui entender que a escola tem uma
parcela de culpa desse nosso medo de
falar em público
saiu uma pesquisa no passado no jornal
inglês de sangue onde ele diz que o
maior medo das pessoas é o de falar em
público é maior inclusive que o medo da
morte
não que o desastre está morto agora
estou muito bem aqui conversando com
vocês e nós temos também esse mesmo medo
de falar em público é um medo que nós
temos de falar com as pessoas as quais
nós não conhecemos
para isto basta você se lembrar do
último encontro que você teve alguém
dentro de um elevador aquele enquanto
solitário aquele silêncio constrangedor
onde provavelmente um dos dois só com
celular e fingiu que estava lendo uma
mensagem eu tive outra professora que me
ensinou muito porque nadar as provas
dela de consulta
aí pensei poxa vida porque não tive uma
professora dessas ano 6ª série
aí eu fui vendo que a consulta faz parte
da nossa rotina fora da escola
o médico com consultas exames se reúne
com uma equipe para fazer a cirurgia nos
seus pacientes
o advogado pesquisa o código penal as
leis para defender o seu cliente
o engenheiro uma calculadora para fazer
os cálculos estruturais da sua obra
o músico leva a cola para o estúdio na
hora de gravar suas músicas e o padre
gente até o padre ele vê a mesma missa
todos os domingos
então a escola é um ambiente
completamente diferente do ambiente que
a gente vive fora dela
aí eu fui sendo impressionado por esses
professores e falei tá aí você é um
deles
eu quero ser um professor que provoca
espanto mas para isso precisava fazer
uma pós graduação
aí o curso de mestrado e depois de
alguns anos uma professora que era
coordenadora pedagógica de uma faculdade
me chamou para ser professor no curso de
educação física e me deram disciplina de
futebol e futsal
eu estou lá na primeira aula prática na
quadra o que aconteceu uma briga
só que agora não eram dois vizinhos que
bastava colocar a mão em cima da cabeça
e segurá los
eram dois marmanjos cara bem mais altos
que eu a minha direita um policial
militar
quase da minha idade a minha esquerda o
metro 85 pesando 82 quilos de puro
músculo um daqueles freqüentadores de
academia e eu ali no meio dos dois
aí eu tomei uma decisão corajosa eu
acabei aula mais cedo um outro dia eu
voltei pra faculdade
escrevi no quadro eu acredito em vocês
eu tinha que acreditar neles
senão não faria mais sentido o seu
professor só tem eu fui surpreendido por
esses alunos porque eles passaram a
acreditar em mim muito mais do que eu
estava acreditando neles e tudo que eu
pedia para desfazer eles faziam de forma
melhorada e ampliada
eu fui buscar entender por que isso
acontecia
eles eram alunos que estudavam à noite
trabalhava durante o dia nos mais
diversas áreas além de policial e de
freqüentadores da academia tinha tinha
também motorista de ônibus operador de
telemarketing trabalhador da construção
civil enfim eram pessoas que trabalhava
o dia inteiro estavam lá a noite
buscando diploma para melhorar de vida
esses esses alunos me espantaram
bastante
e aí eu fui juntando essas informações
em escrever um livro falando das coisas
que estão mudando o mundo
aí eu falei da globalização do
consumismo das diferenças do poder
o fanatismo e falei também da internet
ela está muito presente na nossa vida
a internet está presente na escola
embora a escola não esteja aceitando
ainda isso aí eu vou trazer uma uma
frase de rubem alves professora
ele fala assim tudo o que a escola tenta
ensinar instalar nos livros e na
internet
cada um professor provocar um espanto ea
verdade essas crianças parece que já
estão nascendo informatizadas conectados
plugados elas estão em rede
parece que o lugar onde elas vieram já
existia toda essa tecnologia que eles
usam
eles estão nos ensinando a usar isso é o
momento de nós reconhecemos que a
educação não é mais algo vertical
imposto de cima para baixo autoritário o
conhecimento agora ele se dá em redes é
horizontal onde se espalha é aluno
ensinando o aluno eo professor
permitindo que as crianças nos ensina a
usar esses aparelhos
esses pequenos aparelhos celular ipod
tablets
ali dentro estão todas as informações
que os livros didáticos das escolas
colocam para os seus alunos ali dentro
tem várias salas de vídeos vários
laboratórios milhares de bibliotecas
toda a nossa história está ali dentro de
tudo o que aconteceu o que está
acontecendo hoje por exemplo em que vai
e muita coisa do que vai acontecer estão
dentro desses aparelhos
então cabe o professor provocar o
espanto na sala de aula usando essas
tecnologias
uma sugestão e falando um professor que
provoca espanto
durante o mestrado eu fui pesquisar
professores e foram perseguidos pelo
regime militar no brasil durante a
ditadura
como hoje é o dia internacional dos
direitos humanos em uma praça uma
professora que me impressionou muito
essa professora ela era simples
diante do partido comunista e ela
ajudava as pessoas que lutavam contra a
ditadura militar
ajudava de forma escondida porque tem um
detalhe nessa história
o marido dela era militar e segundo suas
palavras ele caçava comunistas
ele literalmente estava comunistas
então essa professora me contou que
quando o marido dela chegava dessas
cassadas
ele tirava a roupa suja e colocava para
lavar iria tomar banho e depois jantar
ela pegava essa roupa e vasculhavam os
bolsos atrás de bilhetes onde viu
inscritos através de códigos
o nome da próxima vítima do seu marido
ela pegava ela aprendeu a decifrar esses
códigos colocar os seus filhos num
carrinho e sair pelas ruas de campo
grande
e não era uma cidade da grande tela
tocava a campainha da casa da pessoa a
pessoa vendo que era ela
do jeito que ela está lá ela fugia então
essa professora 1 provocou espanto
porque ela arriscou a vida dela a salvar
a vida de outras pessoas
eu aprendi com essa professora que antes
de nós provocamos neste pan
nós precisamos aprender a decodificar os
códigos que os exemplos brilhantes
trazem com eles quando na verdade só
querem a nossa atenção
os códigos estão nesses alunos do
período noturno e trabalho o dia inteiro
estão buscando no ensino superior
melhorar de vida ser alguém diferente às
vezes na própria família
esses professores que provocam o espanto
de fala roubo em alta e eu fico
analisando a minha trajetória como aluno
e professor
os autos e os baixos que eu tive os
tropeços as vezes que eu levantei e eu
confesso para vocês
e todas as vezes que eu procurei ser
professor
eu procurei ser o melhor aluno eu nunca
fui para ser o professor que eu sempre
sonhei em ter a partir de agora eu quero
ser um professor e também provoca
espanto
muito obrigado